so
what i can do in fact is i can recite
for you a couple of verses from the
quran because what you believe is
they have they are known through the
revelation and i can recite for you
maybe 10 20 second verses and translate
for you and show you what i think it
will give you more of a flavor of what
you believe
sure okay do what you will
[Music]
so the quran states in the end of
chapter 59
[Music]
foreign
here's allah
that there is no god worthy of worship
except for him the king the holy the one
free from all defects the giver of
security the watch over his creatures
the mighty the compeller the supreme
glory be to him
glory be to god high is he above all
that they associate as partners with him
he is allah the creator the inventor of
all things the bestower of forms to him
belong the best names all that is in the
heavens and the earth glorify him and he
is the almighty the all-wise so these
are i would say the two
potentially the two best verses that
summarize
for us so right so it's an attempt to
use a multiplicity of virtues to decide
to define a supreme source of good
so okay i have a technical question for
you a procedural question i guess
um
when we're talking so you sang those
verses and then so here's what happened
i asked you that question you sang those
verses or chanted them it's or
combination
okay but there's a there's a melodic
element to that and i don't understand
the language and then you translated
them and so why approach the answer to
to my question in that manner
because we believe that the quran in its
original language
has an element in it or has of has a
virtue if you like to it or an attribute
to it which cannot be felt or
experienced
phenomenologically if you like
through um just mere translation
we believe so yeah and so what what
purpose does that serve in the
discussion with someone like me
what it would do hopefully because we
believe the quran has divine qualities
itself
the quran itself has divine qualities so
we believe number one it's a cure
we believe there's a physic it's
actually a physical cure as well as a
spiritual cure
we believe that it's a guidance
we believe that
it's it's something which will
literally put you in a psychological
state of ease
so in a sense what it will do it
hopefully you know will
have an effect on you which is
physiological maybe psychological
and in a sense it's like giving you
something to taste rather than just
explaining what it tastes like
you know and um so that's why
i feel this how do you know when that's
how do you know when that's appropriate
and when it's not
it's i mean you obviously don't all the
well but you don't yeah i don't mean
that i mean no but but so that's why i
asked the questions yeah obviously
you're making distinctions you're not
you're not doing what you just did with
what it is
i want to give you the full islamic
experience you see yeah okay okay you
know what i mean so yeah okay part of it
is to part of it is to let you hear what
the quran sounds like
you